hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm brandy price
today um there's a reactor out there
named Tyrone Magnus yeah yeah he has
like almost 300,000 followers whatever
whatever anyway some dude at NBC did a
little news report about him oh I think
he interviewed Tyrone and everything
what I'm not jealous I'm not jealous I
didn't book you I'm not jealous
you're [ __ ] jealous now we're gonna
watch this and you're gonna support him
okay
post comments down below usual of notes
thank you enjoyed my reaction it denied
let's rather share 1 million subscribers
truth yeah the YouTube sensation that's
what I call myself legit that video is a
video of the person watching another
video you are seeing there whatever
emotions that video brings out of them
if you come to a tyrone magnus video or
to my page you're going to see reactions
videos where i am watching a trailer
watching any type of video of comedy
skate no matter what it is
and giving you my honest reaction to
what i'm saying and I've created a
following and is it big enough following
to the point where you know that's to
certain either popularity
he's got more than that now personality
you look shy he does like super shy
doesn't he oh no serious one of those
kids that was always told you should be
on TV one day a subscriber sent me a Man
of Steel trailer the kid in me came out
you know I'm not afraid to be me you
know one camera so I mean I think that
appeals to people I think the fact that
someone can really just let loose be
there and a child without any
obstructions
this is me acting crazy there's
something about that magic of wow
he loves this as just as much as I do
which one I want to see more are tonight
it was three five five
if I get the ps4 I'm buying both on but
a lot of y'all been telling me that the
computer that I got is fine
like just give them on PC so maybe I'll
just get the most pride leader of the
Autobots I'm Batman The Dark Knight
there you go
that was much of an impression tyrant
you get in a little better a little bit
more Google Adsense and YouTube so when
I review every YouTube account if you'd
like to make money on YouTube you can
connect for your adsense account to your
YouTube account that's what shows you
the commercials before you watch a video
or in the middle of the day or after a
video we get paid according to how many
views of you so don't skip the ads
people there was a story that I read
about a certain general or captain or
whatever certain food this was years ago
before we had steel ships but what he
would do is if they were invading
new country he would instruct his men to
burn the ships so that the man
psychologically there that they had to
fight harder so they could take the
enemy ship that was their only way back
you're getting this info first but I've
already given my two weeks to my job
because this is taken care of I do like
my job I love this I'd rather do
something and II see news fans thanks
for checking out our YouTube channel
subscribe by clicking on that button
down here and then click on any of the
videos over here to watch the latest
interviews show highlights and digital
exclusives thanks for watching
yeah Wow Wow okay so really shocked by
how serious that was a part of me is
like I'm so happy for him I'm really
happy imparted a very lustful like I
want to put my penis in him I thought
you I thought you were gonna say you
wanted to lick him yeah it comes with
jealousy like I feel like in order to
get over the jealousy I have to have sex
with Tyrone probably I think I would
love to have sex with Tyrone I think he
might be down for it
no he's black he has a big penis you
want to put him in me but I've no okay
with that Tyrone I got a small butthole
I know that's it so that was a really
[ __ ] serious reaction doesn't call
for like serious dramatization of
everything but no it's cool that he got
to get his story out there I love out
you know it's everything he was saying
is true he does explain quickly like why
reaction videos are fun for people and
he also does show that he is himself in
front of the camera you know it's more
comfortable doing stupid stuff than he
does just doing a simple interview yes
because he was like at one point you see
him clears
like you see him get a little nervous
about it
like a comic strip went in there dislike
yeah exactly
and you can kind of see it going down
going under yeah like Tyrone's dick
going down my throat
1 billion [ __ ] its call tire rub oh
the CP fix up we're mapping to famous
for us now
Bobbie though I don't want talk to y'all
my tire impression I wear clothes things
read like Superman you calling Tyrone
Magnus or tyrant crawling come on Tyrone
oh you don't have a job anymore what's
up man are you doing that's like you
better pick up I know he doesn't have a
job anymore so yeah I got Brandi here
with me we're literally filming a video
right now we just reacted to the NBC
story yeah I'm filming a video and I am
you're technically guest starring on my
channel now through my phone ok good
good
dude I didn't know how serious this
video was gonna be
it was like no it look it looked cool it
turned out really well the dramatization
was definitely felt I was just a little
I found it a little funny how how super
serious it was considering what your
channel consists of doesn't make such a
serious video over like a comedy kind of
channel I will definitely say that after
watching it and brandy if you want to
say anything to to tie room and I
haven't met him yet from watching it I
was like wow you know what this this is
I can see how this is inspiring for
people to just want to be themselves
thank you for that that's why I'm all
about dick jokes my friend and and
speaking of dick jokes brandy over here
I don't know if you've seen her on my
channel but she was like dark hair and
the boobs now that's Alyssa I mean she
has boobs
but I don't have boobs she doesn't have
details I mean they're kids they're not
I'm the I'm the I girl she's that she
did this and what the Star Wars reaction
with me the first one yeah people is
comment on my
yeah but she was licking her lips and
totally blushing when she was watching
the video I'm pretty sure she will lick
your butthole Tyrone I didn't say that
but actually Ryan said that he wanted to
lick your dick but oh yeah she's the one
she's the one in the NBC she's the one
in the video with me alright man well
I'm gonna wrap up this video but thank
you so much for answering your phone and
taking the time to speak with us you
superstar sensation you alright cool
thanks man I'll talk to you later
we're friends summer friend super tight
really tight
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the dirty checks
check out brand new prices channel fun
[ __ ] on there and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope or if we get enough followers
we can get product placement for its
periscope you don't know a periscope
yeah I don't know what slow leaking I
know it like it looks like it's it's
like no it's life's periscope is like an
app but it's live streaming
oh so you go live and you can see the
chats and attachments there's a live
streaming app yeah so oftentimes we'll
do live streaming's like licking my
nipples rubbing the phone against my
balls yeah um
walking in Veronica when she's taking a
shower you know walking in on Tyrone
when he's taking a shower yeah yeah he
didn't know I was there what's New
Jersey found his home recorded him he's
a talker huge dick
huge I mean enormous it's been a while
since I've talked about dicks so much in
a video and why not do with me I mean
well you like dick Brandi Brandi likes
dick Brandi likes the D B to the D be
fitted e in the m/v remembering D on